[MUSIC PLAYING]
ISRAEL OLALLA:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
ISRAEL OLALLA:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
JOSE MEDINA: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
ISRAEL OLALLA:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
JOSE MEDINA: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Jurimetria.
What do clients
ask their lawyers?
Clear answers about the
probability of success
and the duration of the case.
Today, a legal
professional faces
an ever-changing
information universe
that moves millions
of legal documents
in which finding the relevant
ones is not an easy task.
Jurimetria allows to make
procedural decisions quickly
through graphical
indicators based
on the cognitive analysis of
millions of [INAUDIBLE] cases.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The most advanced technology
applied to the legal world--
legal argumentation
and procedural strategy
based on predictive criteria
increase likelihood of success
in negotiations and litigation,
speed and reliability
in decision making, the
combination of subject matter
expertise with
innovative technology,
and [INAUDIBLE] new narrative
modules in Jurimetria.
A new experience supporting
from professionals
in building legal arguments or
deciding their legal strategy.
Never before, the
legal professional
could analyze a case and
define a procedural strategy
based on predictive criteria
with such a fast, simple,
and reliable tool.
A new dimension in
predictive litigation.
- Jurimetria.
- Discover it in
www.jurimetria.es.
- Wolters Kluwer.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[END PLAYBACK]
JOSE MEDINA: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]